The Witcher features a cèlle cast and
there's no doubt the fans have
recognized of the show's phenomenal
actors but despite their best efforts
can't quite place them so let's glance
over these performers past
accomplishments and figure out why the
cast of The Witcher looks so familiar
Monster Hunter Geralt of Rivia is
portrayed by Henry Cavill easily the
most recognizable member of the cast
kapil began his career in 2001 and he
earned worldwide fame by playing the
targets live-action version of Superman
to date showing up in DC EU films like
Man of Steel and Batman V Superman dawn
of Justice you might also know him from
Mission Impossible fallouts and from
showtimes two shooters fantasy fans
might also recognize him from his
smaller roles in films like Stardust and
Tristan and Iseult proving that he can
hold his own in a fairy and Dragon
infested setting just as well as on
Krypton in fact cavil admits to loving
and race of CAP Skeets original which
the novels and to being a big fan of
fantasy since he was very young
Freya Allen was subbed to play princess
cirilla aka Siri and on the run royal
with mysterious frightening powers Allen
herself though not quite as younger Siri
is still fairly new to Hollywood a
fresh-faced who's proven she does what
it takes of a long career immediately
prior to the witcher she had a small
role in a BBC miniseries adaptation of
the War of the Worlds and she also
briefly showed up into the badlands like
the young casts of stranger things
Allen's Netflix debut is sure to snag
her more work both within the streaming
services original content as well as and
film who are DHL autre aka the sorceress
Jennifer is fairly new to screen acting
her breakout roles and the BBC's wonder
list followed by a small part in the ABC
murders she's also lent her vocal
talents as a lead path of Robin Locksley
in the futuristic animated series
Sherwood and with such a stunning
performance as a wedge she once at all
it will be a pleasure to see challo
truck continue on to more prominent
roles going forward Jennifer would never
have been able to harness her powers if
not for the influence of Tasya the head
of a magical Academy typically a
character like this will be played as a
hateful stepmother stereotype but in the
very capable hands of
boring to Cyrus's complex intriguing and
sympathetic a character as yennefer
herself as for burrowing her first super
visible role was as Tanya in both parts
of the Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn a
stately manner then graced a set of
Downton Abbey as Edna actor Joey Beatty
brings plenty of plucky charm and a
soothing singing voice to the character
of yes Kia the bard who takes up with
Geralt much so the gruff witch's dismay
before taking up the loot Beatty had
small roles in several television series
including the White Queen another series
featuring strong-willed and powerful
women lovers of historical dramas might
also recognize him from his recurring
role as Pierre on the History Channel's
nightfall the which are both sarcastic
extremely powerful and influential women
and it's hard to get much more powerful
and influential than Colin thei warrior
queen of sintra Colin fee has brought to
life buddy incomparable Jody Mae who's
no stranger to playing a queen having
taken up the mantle of Queen Victoria
and the warrior queen of Jhansi she
appeared in an episode of Game of
Thrones in 2015 as a fortune-teller
named Maggie a small role but
interesting to note considering how much
The Witcher has been compared to the HBO
fantasy series you might also recognize
her from her role as Alice Monroe in the
1992 adaptation of the Last of the
Mohicans starring Daniel day-lewis the
major the amusing name malsuk is
portrayed by Adam levy perhaps
recognized the boat's a superhero fans
from his one-off role as an alien healer
named Amma day in a Supergirl TV series
fans of Hallmark Christmas movies may
have spotted him in 2018 as a Christmas
and whale fashion he's also been part of
his fair share of historical dramas
including AD the Bible continues and
nightfall with Joey Beatty to play the
conniving maid Strega bore the
showrunners cast Danish actor last
mickelson the brother of Hannibal smash
Mickelson unless you're very familiar
with Danish film and television it's
unlikely you've seen a lot of him
however he played the recurring
character viktor petrov in the very
popular Netflix series house of cards
and fans of BBC Sherlock or easily
recognized him as Charles Magnussen from
the episodes his last foul and the empty
hearse it seems Mickelson has a knack
for playing sinister types and his
casting a stretcher Boris spots on in
this regard
the rightful heir of the nilfgaardian
throne cahier as a violent ambitious
prince who single-mindedly pursuing ciri
to use her mysterious powers for his own
ends cahier is portrayed by Amon Ferren
notable for his appearance as richard
horn on the most recent season of David
Lynch's Twin Peaks he also had a
recurring role in the first few episodes
of BBC's adaptation of Agatha Christie's
ABC murders which featured an appearance
by The Witcher co-star Anya cholito as
well he also had a role in the eerie
drama Winchester about a maze-like
mansion and it's strange owner played by
Helen Mirren Dara's played by the young
but very talented Wilson budget Peralta
who's had roles in several that's an own
television series his largest role is
easily that of Aladdin and the BBC
series jamala and Aladdin he also has a
substantial part in the Nickelodeon
series hunter streets and like many
British actors he's found work in a
Charles Dickens inspired series in this
case he started stuck in BBC's
Dickensian Triss Merigold initially
seems like a one-off character whose
purpose is to hire Geralt to slay a
horrible monster instead she becomes a
more prominent player later in the
series
Tris is played by Anna Schaffer who
kicked off her acting career in a rather
impressive way playing from Mill Devane
and Harry Potter and the half-blood
Prince and Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows she was also on the British team
soap opera Hollyoaks for seven years as
Ruby button first stint there spanning
an impressive 242 episodes check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about The
Witcher are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bail so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]